how does that make you feel how does it
make me feel yeah used I'm not in your
top 10 I had 200 yards against the Rams
does that change it well it could you
know it could change we could buy so
many jet skis levy on a few in the Super
Bowl
[Music]
welcome again to Sims and left go or
hands are out because it's happened you
messed up my tattoo the Saints are now
the number one seed in the NFC Sims
thanks a lot I gotta go get a change
well you got the team's right okay got
it right you know put a - how it's gonna
be
Saints definitely number one it looks
like they got home-field advantage now
the Saints are awesome no I'm not gonna
anoint them king of the NFC yet would
they still have to play the Eagles the
Steelers the Panthers twice okay and hey
it's awesome is that win was don't get
me wrong I still think the Rams are the
most dangerous team in the NFC the AFC
makes sense to me
hatreds Chiefs charger Steelers seem
like the cream of the crop with the NFC
there's those top two teams Saints and
ran right and then what other teams
scare you well I mean the Carolina
Panthers are yeah I know but they they
deserve some respect I don't feel like
they're getting on a national or a
national level surprises i if you made
me go who's the next best team in the
NFC are you pickin buckle your seat belt
okay buckle that oh I still like the
Philadelphia Philadelphia Eagles I have
come away watching Philadelphia film on
every week even in their four losses
going they were the better team on the
field they've messed up some situational
play they had nick foles
early when they lost to the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers and fits magic was working
Tennessee Minnesota exactly right I mean
you just look at it Carolina they
dominate the whole game except last 2-3
drives right where they did some dumb
stuff I think with once having Golden
Tate in the fold now and the defense
being better I would still say watch out
for the Eagles I'll tattoo them on right
now I know you woody you know I put that
on your neck hold on someone put
something under this cushion that's
weird
cuz I definitely didn't turn oh you've
got to be kidding my gosh hold on hey no
he's right here yeah it's for you Poe
it's my 2001 college phone this is great
yeah hello hey sims ii went up mike d
down here in new orleans on that
touchdown pal
oh hello michael thomas yes it's great
to hear for me you played awesome on
sunday it was a phenomenal perennial
'it's get down to brass tacks i'm not in
your top 10 i had 200 yards against the
rams is that changing well it could you
know it could change I know I'm kinda
dumb and a little crazy at times but hey
you got an awesome quarterback you got
one of the best play callers in the
history of the sport you think Brandon
cooks is better than me okay I might be
wrong I might have been reevaluate that
you might have to crack the top ten hey
I gotta go I got another call sorry
hello
Simba whatup AFC Offensive Player of the
Month that's right the one the only
James Connor not a top five running back
according to you pal okay I'm James
you're really good man you're awesome I
mean I don't know what to say yeah I'm
not gonna put you in the top five in the
NFL yet there's most touchdowns for the
Steelers in the first eight games since
1950 okay stats don't tell it all they
don't tell the truth right that's
Patrick is the fifth rated quarterback
in football man I don't know what to
tell you you're the fourth best player
on your own offense I can't put you in
the top five running back to the league
I got to go a man Steelers go Steelers
like it hello Christopher holy crap hi
it's Tom hello Tom
hello-o oh great goat one how are you
how are you how are the children
they're good thank you Tom great someone
told me and it's a little upsetting but
you still have me behind Rogers and I
just beat them and I know you wouldn't
really do that it's first of all it's a
team sport Tom and you're awesome man I
mean you're you're one of the greatest
of all time you're just not better than
Rodgers but lately yeah you know you're
not sorry just be quiet I'm talking okay
and then the other thing too is you're
41 and I still have you as one of the
five best quarterbacks in the sport but
I mean you also have awesome players and
coaches around you I'm not trying to
take anything away from you Tom you're
still awesome I'm just trying to keep it
real man Chris how many hugs have we
shared this is hurting my heart we
haven't shared any hug sorry we shared
some vegan ice cream once see yeah
all right great thank you for that phone
call
you shared veganized
not really I just sounded cool this is
Jalen Ramsey you watch the Sims and let
go
[Music]
hello and welcome
it's the doctors Sims and Lefko and
we're here with our new patient Landon
Collins Landon is a shining star of the
New York Giants franchise Landon
I'm just curious as you've gone through
this season and people ask you probing
questions how does it make you feel he's
just trying to make a story out of the
words you were saying you know most
people kind of twist it up and get a
story out of it when you see your friend
Odell be classified with words like
selfish and mean and and egotistical do
you say anything to him do you want to
be his therapist sometimes I know I
don't want to be a therapist because I
know there's a lot more than their head
and we all know I'm there for him I'm
always gonna be a brother phone I feel
for him is that the world is against him
it must feel like that loyalty very
loyal loyalty yeah that's very good
Landon tell us about sake one barky fake
one yes tell me about his quads when you
see this I think they don't like
somebody out I honestly I feel like they
can't hurt somebody can crush somebody
hate with them things what is it like
watching the greatest quarterback in
Giants history have to go through such a
struggling year what's it been like for
you guys to have to deal with those
questions
emotionally Washington got they each and
every week I expect greatness you know I
expect to see greatness because that's
what I've watched when I was growing up
you know and seeing that we have a
losing streak and not getting the wins
and stuff like that it's hard it's hard
not for just him and not for just often
it's hard for the whole team honestly
and we resent be sticking behind Tim
because we know he has it in them you
know how to win so I think we could
figure it out together yeah you lightest
lightest very much the most severe kind
of
lighteth I want to say that for you to
lay on this couch and to do this you
have vaunted yourself yeah into sims and
left Kosala fame top five Hall of Fame
favorite guests playing along with this
absolutely not I can't imagine being a
New York athlete with dozens of cameras
in your face after every game and
they're asking you guys the same
question and nothing they want more than
for you to go
he ain't that good I'm tired of this guy
I would love it if you guys had a place
to release it to like let it all go but
you can't no and I wonder what that's
like as an athlete where like you have a
truth and you can't speak that truth I
put it this way if you assist say that
correct yes and I get trade it and you
get trade it all you get cut or you get
put it to another team yeah you think
those guys would trust you exactly yeah
that's the thing so you don't even think
how are the media gonna twist my words
you go I need to go and look at those
guys in the locker room each and every
day mm-hmm have you ever been in locker
where someone has said something where
you were like I was one guy they say
something about the Eli Apple yeah yeah
and what and so you learned a lot from
that experience right man what were the
days after you said that stuff what for
you personally so me personally it was
just constantly asking a question about
it immediate then just my guys is like
it was kind of the right thing to do but
not that's not the way you have that I
situation right you it was that you
realized that afterwards you were like
that was my truth but the timing wasn't
great
correct I kind of want to ask an
opponent thing or better yet who's that
who's the best player you've had a play
against in general who do you who would
you give that who would you give that
crown to a righteous thank you
Oh Aaron Roger you are the greatest
quarterback we've ever seen please talk
about that Aaron yes oh man is
phenomenal I could tell you one play
already
we had a presence white guy lined up on
17 right so I'm disguised and I'm kind
of down towards the box but I'm actually
going back so for some reason I
understand
and I'm never in this stance a try look
at me and smile and kind of give like a
look giggle and this did something with
his hand 217 I knew it was a signal 217
I looked at 17 I looked at my guy that's
covering them as soon as you say Hut I
try to run before you say a Hut he
already said it I'm already out leverage
touchdown 217 oh my god
so just just a mindset his preparation
for the game his ability to move out of
the pocket and off his back for you
never seen quite a big city besides I
think Brett fought off his back foot
like he does and he's just a great guy
yeah had he giggles and your heart just
sinks I already know what he is doing
already doing that I don't know Le'Veon
time to wake up time to go to the
Steelers facility today it's time to
finally check in and be a good teammate
or we could never go back and watch them
suffer into the ground it's time to go
in and apologize to your teammates tell
them how much you missed football you
heard what they said about you those
offensive linemen how many touchdowns up
they scored James Conner you should
shave his head when you get the camp
think big picture levian so then what's
the big plan angel you can be a part of
a winner
this team can win the Superbowl levian
and you know what that means more
dollars we could buy so many jet skis
levy on a few in the Superbowl mutual
funds with the extra money levy on
mutual funds how many touchdowns do you
think you're going to catch this season
just going nine oh I am gonna take the
under if it goes over nine or over I
will donate $1,000 to the wimbur lease
and their help for the youth in Cambodia
sounds good take us how many
interceptions do you think
gonna have this season I'm gonna go with
seven I'm gonna say that you go over
seven interceptions this year if I'm
wrong I'm going to donate $1,000 to the
fam first charity I'll take that bet how
many completed passes do you think you
will have this season I mean the lines
got to be - it's gonna be just over
average and so - yeah I'm gonna take the
under okay if you get over - I will
donate $1000 to the Special Olympics in
your name so those were our bets before
the season and let's see where we stand
I took the under on nine receiving
touchdowns for Cooper Cup he's at six am
any mystic gamer - you're in trouble
sorry mr. Gambrell yeah every time I
turn on the game he's running down the
sidelines yeah Cooper I'm rooting
against you man yeah I'm not ari take
less money Marcus Peters I said he would
have over seven interception what were
you thinking is there any chance he can
get six a second
absolutely not here absolutely not sorry
Johnny hacker I said he would get under
- he's at one right now oh this is the
one that I got my fingers crossed for
keep running I'm Sean McVeigh fossil
McVeigh you're gonna have a few more
tricks for him before the seasons out
you think I'll lose all three I do now
Marcus Peters though everyone has been
kind of bagging on him especially after
that Michael Thomas catcher and you kind
of you you don't think that's accurate
no I think Mike Marra
Marcus Peters did a lot of good things
listen Michael Thomas is good he's a
huge receiver he made some unbelievable
contested catches and this would be my
big point left go yeah he messed up on
the big touchdown play there's no doubt
about that but what Marcus Peters was
asked to do in that football game
there's only a few corners in football
that you would even ask or put in that
situation yeah it wasn't his best but it
wasn't as horrible as everybody in the
world is trying to make it out to be if
you were to compare me to a quarterback
in terms of my betting who would I be oh
that's an easy one
Carson Wentz yeah exactly not know hello
Nathan Peterman a betting good to see
you oh it's another pick six I'm tired
of this Nathan Peterman slander and I
just want to say Nate I salute you he
does not me
hey Nathan Peterman you may not be super
good at football but that's not the
point
you my friend are providing a service
more honorable than winning your critics
see you relentlessly giving it away to
the other team but not me I see you
taking one for the team your own line
stinks your receiving corps is the worst
in football and shady McCoy is a shadow
of himself this is all a recipe for
failure and you are failing
spectacularly Bill's mafia wants to
treat you like a folding table why are
you doing this why because you're the
man Nate you're the Peter man and you're
falling on that grenade so hard so Josh
Allen takes absolutely no shrapnel in a
city that loves wings Nate you are the
ultimate wingman and that is pretty cool
[Music]
two-week losing streak on somebody in
left go I will not stand for it first
the dragon and then grace we need to cut
this short and there's one man that I
know that's good with the scissors Boris
the barber we are here little Tony
Igor be good this is my man Boris and
Thursday night this is how this works I
got 250 dollars of Bleacher Report's
money I'm gonna put it on this game
Panthers at Steelers Steelers are
favored by four what do you know about
these teams oh I watched few games okay
in there and I know schools are pretty
good yeah
Sanders Panthers not much no we need to
really hear much about them they have
Cam Newton they run the ball really well
it's in Pittsburgh the Steelers are
favored by four I want to split money
with you Boris I want to cut it like you
just cut my hair who are you picking
Mathis and the Boris bet is official
let's go lock Boris bet left go lock
Boris bet let's go lock porous bet
finally we're getting a good Thursday
night football game and I'm hoping Boris
the barber calls this one he's taken the
Panthers plus four in Pittsburgh I likey
do you likey I likey do you like man
plus four whoo this is a great game I
don't like Thursday Night Football first
of all guy just want to state that they
need to have Thursday Night Football
after by week so we can see these teams
at their best or not their best on a
Thursday night I'm gonna take Carolina
Panthers you're feeling it yeah I mean I
don't not gonna say they're gonna win
outright but I think they thought it was
in four yes few weeks ago when the
Steelers lost to the Ravens the first
time everyone was calling out Mike
Tomlin saying they'd lost the culture
fights with Antonio Brown Big Ben what's
up with levy on and you believe after
four straight wins the nation owes Mike
Tomlin an Apollo I do I mean come on and
thank you for bringing it up because we
got to go there yeah if we're all gonna
crap on Mike Tomlin when things go bad
and blame him and oh he set a bad
culture and he you know the team's two
renegade and he has no control then when
things go positively we have to take it
back and all self Scout okay and go dim
well he's obviously fixed things in the
locker room their defense has been
playing better he was a defensive
coordinator I've been around him Dave so
he's fixed that part of the team or and
the Wi-Fi between Ben and Antonio Brown
is working phenomenal so way to go Mike
T keep shutting up all those haters yes
don't just give credit to the coaches
that seemingly scheme Mike Tomlin is
more than just a rah-rah guy ya Tomlin
way to do it for Simms he's out homey I
am the lef koe man we will holla holla
holla at you later enjoy the games
this dude is the same one that had your
pooping in your pants for attention when
you were six don't listen to the Angels
just scumbag pooping in your pants is
cool that I'm Miles Davis
nobody anybody hey what's up homies
thanks for watching subscribe to the BR
YouTube channel
man you're such a millennial also while
you're here we have a lot of other
videos check them out and then what time
does our show come out Wednesday 8 p.m.
be there or be square he ruined it it
was really close